I'd like to begin by digging in if we
can to the question at hand which is
should the West compromise over Ukraine
and it seems to me this question does
cut to the heart of this debate there's
not much disagreement about whether we
should compromise with Russia as anatol
said Western leaders have already
offered to compromise with Russia on an
array of different issues the question
is should we compromise with Russia at
Ukraine's expense and this is where I
think the matter lies let me first
before turning to the specifics of
Ukraine though uh address the general
question of NATO since it is NATO that
is to a certain extent at stake here
although I also want to focus on the
question of Ukrainian sovereignty and
Independence which Anatole didn't touch
on and it's all suggested that NATO
enlargement was a Fateful Error quoting
George Cannon and when I look at Europe
I don't see the evidence of that all
NATO countries that I look at from
Poland to Romania to the Baltic States
into the Balkans are more peaceful than
almost anyone would have expected they'd
have been at the end of the Cold War
when they were released from Soviet
domination and so rather than a Fateful
Error it seems to me that NATO
enlargement has been an extraordinary
success of European and American
diplomacy no one would have predicted in
1991 when the Cold War ended that Europe
could be so straightforwardly pacified
with uh with only a couple of exceptions
democratic governments United the whole
uh a whole life a free end at peace this
is a great success story for Western
diplomacy rather than a faithful error
the question of course today though is
about NATO and Ukraine and I think here
a couple of data points are in order the
first is to say that Ukraine has no
desire to be part of a Russian sphere of
control or to return to the fold of the
Russian Empire Russian President
Vladimir Putin has said that he sees
Ukraine and Russia as one people but the
Ukrainian populace doesn't agree opinion
poll after opinion poll election after
election ukrainians want to be
independent the most recent polls from
the respected key of Institute of
Sociology find 88 of ukrainians want
independence from Russia a majority want
to join NATO and that number has been
increasing over time in all regions of
the country whether Ukrainian speaking
or Russian speaking the trend line is
positive a majority of ukrainians also
say Russia is a hostile State 72 percent
in the latest poll and it's not hard to
understand why ukrainians think that for
the past eight years Ukraine has faced a
set of types of pressure from Russia
economic pressure diplomatic pressure
cyber attacks and of course most
importantly military pressure be the
Russian occupation of Ukraine's Crimea
and the regular fighting that is taking
place in the dombas which is occupied by
russian-backed armed and funded militias
if you listen to the Kremlin talk about
the current crisis a crisis that emerged
because Russia decided to put over a
hundred thousand troops on its border
with Ukraine Russia describes the
question of one of security guarantees
and the irony is that Russia thinks that
it's the country that needs security
guarantees Russia a country with one of
the world's two largest nuclear arsenals
Russia which has one of the world's
three most powerful conventional
militaries thinks that it is a country
that needs security guarantees whereas
when I look at European security the
country most at risk to me seems to be
Ukraine not Russia and so the security
guarantees that the criminal looking for
seem to be not really uh based in fact
but based in something very different
now for the past decade or so the
Kremlin has focused on uh trying to
bring Ukraine back into its orbit there
are lots of people who regret the
collapse of the Soviet Union lots of
people in Moscow who think that
reinvigorating Russian imperial control
over Eastern Europe would be a good
thing for Russia and they've had some
successes uh in recent years but we've
had some failures too which is that the
ukrainians as well as other people on
their border don't want to join them and
so Russia's had to find ways new stories
to invent uh to justify its increasingly
aggressive policies to these countries
you don't grab your neighbor's territory
as a way of achieving security against
them uh they get that that's exactly
what Russia has done
the reality is that what we're talking
about here is not primarily Russia's
security if you had as many nuclear
missiles as Russia does missiles that
are launched from planes that are
launched from icbms on spread across
Russia's territory from submarines that
are impervious to Russian to I'm sorry
to Nato attack you wouldn't feel
insecure and I think it's implausible
that the Kremlin seriously feels
threatened by NATO forces which anyway
are only a tiny fraction of what they
were during the peak of the Cold War
it's Russia not the United States or
NATO that's been building up its
military forces in Europe since 2008
Russia's launched an extraordinary
military modernization that's been very
successful as we've seen on battlefields
like in Syria it's Russia that's rolled
out a set of new Hypersonic missiles
that has the most advanced Hypersonic
missile program of any country in the
world and so when I hear Russians
talking about insecurity I struggle to
understand what reality this is based on
every military analyst that looks at the
military balance thinks that it's
shifted substantially in Russia's favor
over the past couple of years I think
Anatole exaggerates when he says that
NATO would struggle to defend borders in
Eastern Europe but there's a grain of
Truth there which is that Russia is
substantially stronger today in pure
military terms than it was a decade ago
which again makes Russia's demands for
security seem even more puzzling to me
in fact I think when Russia talks about
security what it really means is
sovereignty it doesn't like the fact
that Ukraine wants to be an independent
country last summer in June President
Putin published a very high profile
article still published on the kremlin's
website which argued that quote Ukraine
can only have true sovereignty in
partnership with Russia that's what this
is about should Ukraine be Sovereign or
should it be a second tier State
answering to the kremlin's whim and so
when I think about compromising with
Russia in the current crisis I say yes
absolutely let's find ways to compromise
with Russia in the ways that Western
leaders have already proposed but if it
comes to compromising Ukraine's
sovereignty I say no Ukraine sovereignty
doesn't threaten Russia Russia's
military is stronger than it's been in
the past 30 years and when Russia talks
about security what it means is
domination that's something we simply
should not accept